qu'il soit à montréal ou à l'étranger
hors de question pour denis coderre de
changer ses habitudes gens d'affaires
politiciens
le maire multiplie les événements et des
poignées noires
son but est simple ici faire le plein de
contrats en chine la deuxième économie
de la planète 70 gens d'affaires
l'accompagnent dans cette mission le
fait d'être présent à tous les niveaux
tant sur le plan institutionnel que le
milieu des enfants avec un milieu
politique
pour eux les chinoises qui voient là
c'est que tout le monde parle d'une
seule et même voix et ça ce n'est pas
une mission fort prometteuse affirme le
maire jusqu'à maintenant neuf contrats
ont été signés depuis son arrivée et
plusieurs autres devraient l'être au
cours des prochains jours deux tours 6
parmi les projets qui ont progressé
celui du cirque du soleil
le fleuron québécois ouvrira finalement
son premier bureau en chine après s'être
associé à une firme locale
les retombées de ce pied-à-terre
pourrait être encore plus importante que
celle de toutes les productions à las
vegas on parle de créer vrai 30 emplois
par nouveau spectacle
donc si on parle en chine de créer
quatre cinq six nouveaux spectacles
permanents
c'est autant d'emplois conquérant chez
nous au québec
entente de recherche avec lui pendant un
investissement technologie le mercredi
et espère aussi donner un nouveau
souffle aux relations canada chine il
s'est même permis de devenir
l'ambassadeur de suspectible j'ai parlé
avec
l'estrie d'o'hara monde est pareil puis
le message était clair
on parle tous ces deux mêmes bois
les ai salués
mais monsieur trudeau à son nom
autrement un changement de ton par
rapport aux années impaires indique jean
chrétien
il se trouve lui aussi en chine pour
participer à la rencontre annuelle du
conseil d'affaires canada chine parce
que les relations vont s'améliorer par
les gens que j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer
depuis je suis arrivé dirait qu'ils ont
lancée beaux souliers
l'opération charme du mercader se
poursuit jusqu'à vendredi
ici mon côté radio canada chagrin